the most followed person on YouTube is
this guy who is a gamer his name is
PewDiePie PewDiePie and he is the worst
ha ha ha why do people hate me
I am so nice why would he stabbed me in
the back like this this hurts more than
any dagger then any racial slur you know
from one Caucasian to another I am
disappointed I feel like someone just
took my lunch even though it said it had
my name on it I feel disgusted I really
thought me and Perez were gross because
he always writes such wonderful articles
about me such as PewDiePie is the worst
I am the worst everyone we've hit this
top up top 10 worst youtuber number one
coming up pewdiepie he is literally the
worst PewDiePie responds to n-word
backlash by sharing fellow white
youtubers own offensive on Perez as a
fellow white youtuber I know you used to
do YouTube as well I am a little
disappointed that you met tag that says
discuss it grow the [ __ ] up it was all a
favor
you know you wish I lost all my
subscribers and went away I wish you
trip on your shoelaces surely no one
else could possibly make fun of me on a
day like this because it's my day is
ruined at this point I still oh no no no
no DJ come be he responded
after all these years of fighting this
war this war against pewdiepie and the
bro army know me Dylan we already
surrendered we already gave to you by
all our money goddamn right they did now
what's the deal you would have to give
me all of your money
Groot pocket change for someone rich and
famous like me really I mean you can
have it back I don't really care I just
don't like you BG kumbi I just don't
like you Dylan was even forced through a
collaborative comedy video with
PewDiePie against his will that's true I
forced Dylan and D hacker because I beat
all of you he thought your hate could
rise above me [ __ ] you for even thinking
that I am the strongest handsomest bleep
most attractiveness best youtuber if you
come against me I'm going to come at you
at least 20 times harder and I'm going
to come swing it you can't beat me
because my rows are harder than anyone
so BG kumbi keep crying okay what the
[ __ ] are you going to do about it
still making fun of us because I am you
know why I keep attacking you
because I enjoy it I find pleasure in
destroying little hater scumbag like you
that was your mom laughing at you from
the other room I could hear that still
pathetic I just want to say the qtpie
humiliated me this latest video in rows
sitting on the world stage
that's goddamn right I need people
million how many people watch your video
8000 attic now I'm just trying to form
something of a life after it all got
turned upside down today yeah what are
you going to do about it
compute 'if i don't think i will forget
this you won't forget it because it's
touched i tattooed it and your brain I
went inside your brain I [ __ ] it and I
tattooed myself right in there
I mean your brain forever son that's why
you're my child spoilers I didn't want
to say anything but I made you if you
want this war between us to continue and
so be it
you know I won't lie I've made a few
videos on 25
you made a few you made a fit that's
rich
your whole channel is pretty much
dedicated to me it's [ __ ] sad look
how many disgusting you know I thought
YouTube was against cyberbullying this
sort of stuff should not be tolerated
he's clearly trying to destroy me
I rise above the hate I am strong just
look at this video you did about me put
a [ __ ] shirt on so as most of you
know by now I'm going to YouTube or with
PewDiePie this war that's been going on
for many centuries even though I have
one I'm not going to stop this is in
2014 anyway my response to PewDiePie is
back off amen
that's all you had to say that's all you
literally had to say you you just had to
say back off and I'll back up I swear to
you I do not like you in that way okay
what do you not even a
[Music]
House hollard area so hot and awesome
very awesome how dare you say that I
don't have a haircut
and a big success [ __ ] you you don't
even have a three pack that's right in
the spring of my youth in a great meadow
go out with someone your own age you
don't know you don't know what I'm
interested in okay you don't know if I
like you or not
he can't just say that you can't just
say that I liked you that doesn't make
it true
don't listen he's trying to manipulator
do not listen to him he's telling life
all right
also I found that beautifies girlfriend
has a crush on my friend Dylan no no no
no no no no no you had it he hacked her
mind cuz he had she actually makes cutie
pie dress up as Dylan the hacker him in
three Oh No otherwise she can't make
love to know this man it's feeding you
life this man is practically the medium
watch out
yeah PewDiePie is a pervert and he's be
normal and date men his own age why I
can date whoever man i won
[ __ ] to you for even saying that and no
I do not dress up like Dylan the hacker
and 3-pack to make love with Marzia okay
I don't have to do it that's war has
only
we gun let's see what else he has to say
in this stupid video
hashtag resist beautify tweet it if you
want to support you can hashtag old you
bored of hunger strikes I'm going to go
on a hunger binge I'm taking it one step
further I'm going to eat snacks until p5
apologizes I'm going to eat until I grow
into a giant sumo wrestler well BG can
be prepared to explode because I am
never and I think never apologizing to
your sorry ass that can squash PewDiePie
like a bug just by sitting on him I
officially challenge PewDiePie to a sumo
wrestling college oh you winter has to
spend a night locked in a closet with a
male sex offender okay okay loser has to
eat 1,000 mung beans you just said what
the loser had to do what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
loser has to get scalped by a tomahawk
by a real-life Indian Lord that seems
fair
that seems fair I know a guy that can
hook us up and do the scalp link
although not to be mean or anything but
it looks like there's not much work
needed to be done there you're balding
is what I'm saying
loser has to hook car batteries up to
his nipples okay alright is that it's
not how we're going to do this BG kumbi
well I got some real to settle well
Jesus loser has to get Starbucks for at
least a week
in fact I challenge to you by two who
can take more electrical shocks contest
we both look ourselves up to a car
battery and go vote for volt until one
of us passes out I accept your challenge
arrested UMP an entire bowl of corn
flakes over their heads no no I'm not
doing it I'm not that [ __ ] up dude
what the [ __ ] I'm not going to waste
corn flakes for some stupid [ __ ] dude
think with your head not with your
breath I am prepared to accept that
challenge however if you lose you have
to watch grown-ups too with me and loser
have to delete their mixtape I challenge
you to a pee drinking contest we
urinate in each other spaces merged your
DNA with me PewDiePie right this is an
open challenge I want to merge with
PewDiePie I want to become I want to
share my consciousness with a man in
cell number 1 subscribe person on the
other just like Sadako versus kayako
hello how's your breath money is here
he's him me
cutie pie and I will finally achieve the
highest level of YouTube together
YouTube will make us a special plaque
for 1 billion subscribers made out of
the bones of all of the youtubers ground
into a wood chipper sacrificed in our
honor we will finally become the
greatest YouTube star to ever live thank
you
well BG kumbi I want you to know that
that was a brushin nonsense you can't
merge DNA I've tried it before it's
impossible it was bad enough with 3 pack
we can't do this anymore if you're not
joking there may be one person that
knows how to do this and his name is
we must contact him we must we must find
this man his name it
Jax Black Sea